left hand in general Richmond thank you
very much for being on the program today
you're leading the NATO effort to try
and get key supplies to member states
around the world what is it you're doing
what we are doing an operation and
singularly here in the in supreme
headquarters Allied powers Europe in
Mons Belgium is a strategic coordination
so we do this for a living and we do
this in order to accomplish our normal
main mission the principal
responsibilities we ask for for the ions
which is preserving peace in the era for
that to be able to deter and defend
against any aggression on the framework
of that mission we have dedicated teams
whose Daley's job it is to to plan and
move supplies troops and equipment
across the the area of responsibility so
we can with this mechanism much actually
the requests from donations given to the
Clearinghouse in in Brussels with the
available strategic airlift so that the
nations will provide that and this is
then the rapid and mobility mechanism
and this was actually used as we as I'm
talking to a British show by Turkish
airplanes over the Easter weekend to
ship medical supplies and personal
protective equipment to London over the
eastern weekend that personal protective
equipment it's something that is causing
a lot of worry here in the UK reports
that there's a global shortage and that
now the advice has changed so that
doctors and nurses in the UK can reuse
some of the gowns
is there enough protective equipment to
go around I mean it's it's not for NATO
to answer that question that the problem
of the the stocks I think everybody was
taken a little bit of God by by this
crisis no one was really completely
understanding the the full expanse of
the other of the health crisis we are
facing the shortage is global what we
can bring to the total to support the
the teams that are dealing with that is
managing the coordination of the
strategic lab
airlift which can pick up the personal
protective equipment where they are not
what the nations decide to do with the
personal protective equipment and the
reuse of them is really a national
decision and how do you work out what
of protective equipment and medical
supplies goes to each different country
we process we process the requests that
are posted by the by the nations to the
Coordination centre the flavouring house
in Brussels and that we simply answer to
a request of the nation's but what we
don't do we do not interfere with what
the nation's do on a national basis and
I mean all the nations have taken all
appropriate measures to deal with the
crisis in their own boundaries and to
protect and save their own people in an
emergency and that is all right so we
are not interfering at that we are just
giving some coordination measures to
enable the process to go faster now
there's reports that some equipment from
China intended to go to France was
intercepted and they're not going to the
United States are you seeing countries
looking out for themselves in this
crisis that's not what I'm saying what
I'm saying is that the initial initial
phase of the crisis the nations had to
react very quickly in face or father of
a crisis that was completely unheard of
before so they all appropriate measures
to make both choices but of course when
you make a choice you are always being
able to be criticized afterwards so I'm
not referring specifically to any
country or any decision that was made we
are in in the context of our four world
crisis with with a shortfall of
equipment that was not considered a
strategic before this crisis burst out
and so we have to cope with it okay now
to buy our word the former defense
minister here in the UK has criticized
the NATO response saying notte needs to
wake up and do more China and Russia
we've seen being very quick and getting
a medical supplies to some European
countries has made have been too slow
let me get back to what NATO's core
mission is and principal
responsibilities towards the citizens of
this of these islands we are here too we
have been created that fundamentally to
preserve peace in the era in the
euro-atlantic era to do that we need to
be able to deter and defend and this
mission is continuing so we have no
impact from the cob
honor on the accomplishment of a mission
on our posture of deterrence now what
NATO is not the first responder for this
crisis and that is pretty obvious
because it's interagency
intergovernmental and it's much wider
than the simple military response we can
provide and we do provide support to
other agencies I mean all the NATO
allies the militaries of the NATO allies
have been providing this kind of support
in their own countries so far we have
deployed 4,000 medics doctors nurses
across the different nations we have
deployed a 250 field hospital which
amounts to something like 25,000 beds we
are providing this coordination
mechanism of with the rapid air mobility
over 100 flights had been have been
conducted to our to ship that is the
equipment so saying that NATO is slow to
wake up and start doing anything is not
fair because we are doing quite a lot
and you're very robust they're defending
and NATO saying that is unfair to
describe the response it's too slow and
there's also been some criticism of the
EU they've apologized to Italy for not
acting so quickly do you think at this
times of crisis people turn to these big
multilateral organizations like the
European Union like NATO have they been
found wanting the big organizations are
something that is very reassuring but
you need to understand what what the
purpose of the organization is an
organization that NATO is not a disaster
relief organizations not being created
to do that it's been created to defend
Europe against the Soviet Union in the
in the 50s so we have now changed the
mission the mission is still defending
and deterring this is the core mission
and this is not going to change what we
can bring to bear upon is the skills we
have are the structures we are operating
and the professionalism of our teams we
have nimza who's a whose job it is to do
crisis management of course it's more in
a military sense of it but actually a
crisis is a crisis so if we have that
the the resources and the directives and
the guidance to conduct a crisis plan
we have all the professionals to do so